the Joe Rogan experience go dig up those
old tweets and want to find out things
that you said or you know and and this
it is similar to that feeling of
watching a public execution right
everyone's so excited for it to happen
like they're just they pile on they'll
go on your Instagram leave tons and tons
of like terrible comments gotten
canceled yeah it's like okay good did
you really feel does that make your day
better what are you making a face for
Jamie what's bad I just found something
dark talk about this about hamsters
eaten they're the last public hanging
there was 20 I was like a huge media
event like 20,000 people travel to
Kentucky to watch it happen there's a
see a white woman hanging a blaster she
was the local sheriff she didn't go
through with it because of probably the
attention so some eager volunteers did
it and while this is all going on
there's like a media circus people were
eating hot dogs drinking lemonade
camping out overnight there's a huge
event and it was 1936 oh boy what did
they say he did I was looking for but
set up there he scroll up it said he was
wanted for the rape of a seven year old
woman that was the woman go scroll up
scroll up a little higher a little
higher a little higher there it is okay
yeah see des des confessed to the rape
and murder of a seven year old
Lycia Edwards a capital crime under
Kentucky law and one that fell upon the
local sheriff to punish I could appoint
the deputy sheriff to deputize any
citizen to spring the trap Thompson told
reporters as she stoically resigned
herself to the role but to do that would
inflict an unpleasant job upon someone
else so she's she decided this
disgusting job she was going to do it
and then she started not to it and then
she couldn't do it not a good look the
woman throws anything post-slavery post
1865 there were so many crimes that
people were arrested for that were
nothing where men were being forced to
do labor so what what it would happen
was because the fact that
slavery was now abolished these men
would be loitering right people didn't
know what the [ __ ] to do like imagine
your slave your whole life you grew up a
slave and then all sudden you're free
like you're like what the [ __ ] yeah what
do I do well they would just arrest you
yeah and then make you do hard labor in
jail for nothing
yeah they that's essentially figured out
how to make slavery legal it did it for
decades yeah I mean they don't sort of
do it today
sure yeah I mean when you make a guy
work in jail for a dollar a day whatever
the [ __ ] they pay how is that not
slavery yeah we've given him gruel what
are you giving them white bread and
[ __ ] shitty meatloaf what are you
feeding him it's one of those things
where I'm like we we get so mad at like
a lot of the current stuff that's
happening with like who what we're
supposed to be saying you know like the
right pronouns to use all that stuff and
it's like yeah okay I'll try to say the
right pronouns that's a pretty easy fix
how about we go back and like kind of
correct some of this 400 years of
slavery and oppression that we did for
black people oh is it because it's
harder to do probable problems a them is
easy yeah captain pink hair I think the
real problem is these communities like
they've never recovered like places like
Baltimore
there's there's certain communities that
have been the same forever and Southside
Chicago is another one right there's
these communities that they're just
they're [ __ ] with riddled with crime
and drugs and so many people in and out
of jail and this constant recidivism
rate yeah you grow up there you're
you're in that system like they would
have to maybe a terrible public well
like sure you have to work gangs as
early as you can drugs I mean the people
that are heroes in your neighborhood are
drug dealers so what do you how do you
fix that boy there's no effort put to
that needs of like just like a like a
systemic national effort on the federal
level to step in and do something to
these communities and do it on a scale
that we do in other countries when we
bomb the [ __ ] out of them right and also
just admit that we're racist like when
apartheid after apartheid happened they
had like a date look there was a couple
days of reckoning or whatever it was
called where everyone went up and they
were like
these are the things I did really yeah
these are the things I did um these are
like the laws I broke and it was like
this like terrible like cathartic admit
to your racism and then let's try to
heal after that and then we're all just
like no we're not racist and I'm like
pretty racist well some people are
racist but what's racist is that these
communities suffered under a system that
was completely imposed because of racism
right in the 1800s and then in the early
1900s and during the civil rights era
this is all I mean that that there's no
denying that it's the echoes of at least
ancient racism that needs to be somehow
another addressed but I mean how do you
address that like people some people
want reparations and like the idea of it
makes sense right clearly someone
profited right there are to this day
there's corporations you can trace their
money back to slavery right right well
seems like they should pay so yeah like
if you look at a giant plantation and
they used to have slaves and they
profited off those slaves and that
plantation is somehow they're still in
operation today right I don't know if
that's the case but if it was like
where'd you get your money yeah what'd
you do and then how do you go back
giving it back how do you go back will
you give it back to ya do you give it
back to the ancestors of the people who
were slaves and the problem is like if
you give people money I don't think it
fixes the problem I think to fix the
problem there has to be some sort of we
beaten this horse to death on the show
unfortunately and then I don't have any
solutions no one ever has one I don't
know what it would be but I think there
has to be some way to clean up
communities and I don't know how you
would do that
I mean I've no idea how do you how do
you go to a place like Southside Chicago
has more murders than Afghanistan mm-hmm
I mean it's bad there right [ __ ] bad
if I'm making that up I don't think so I
think you're right but but that's the
thing it's like this is such like an
unsolvable problem and the stuff that
people go after on Twitter or like the
social justice stuff is so easy to do
and it's like yeah of course that's what
you're gonna like you
have a hard day or whatever a shitty job
you have and then you come home you see
someone got mad at something or did
something wrong and you get to be like
yeah this person you're cancelled yeah
and then you close your computer or
whatever or you watch people retweet it
and you're like you're like I did do
something today I'm an activist yeah I'm
an activist
[Applause]